je n'ai jamais vu ça
moi je suis triste pour mon pays nous
sommes en guerre pour la peste on avait
les rats pour le covid on a les enfants
de l'Assemblée nationale
bonjour Merci il est 19h52 merci
Eric nolo Yann Moix
avant de venir
c'est très réussi c'est très réussi
merci d'être là alors lors de sa
conférence de rentrée le ministre de
l'Éducation annoncé que cette longue
robe ample serait interdite au nom de la
laïcité et depuis cette décision fait
énormément parler c'était la rentrée des
classes aujourd'hui regardez petit
requin
ce matin c'était la rentrée pour les
écoliers français une rentrée marquée
par cette petite phrase prononcée
dimanche dernier par Gabriel Attal et
qui a provoqué une véritable onde de
choc j'ai décidé on ne pourrait plus
porter la Baya à l'école le ministre de
l'éducation nationale souhaite donc
faire interdire ce vêtement considéré
parfois comme un signe au stand-attoir
pour rappel la Baya déjà pointé du doigt
l'an dernier est une robe longue et
ample qui couvre le corps et qui est de
plus en plus porté par de jeunes filles
musulmanes à l'école mais qui selon elle
n'a rien de religieux je connais des
filles qui les portent alors qu'elles
sont pas du tout musulmanes juste parce
qu'elles trouvent ça beau elle trouve sa
confortable si certains ont salué cette
initiative d'autres notamment à gauche
dénoncent une forme de discrimination
envers la communauté musulmane et je
pense qu'on a pas besoin de ça dans
notre pays alors interdiction de la
bailler à l'école pour ou contre
comprenez-vous merci en tout cas à nail
art d'être là merci nella 16 ans merci
tu es en colère toi la suite de
l'interdiction de la Bahia dans les
écoles et merci à ton papa mida d'être
avec nous également merci à vous deux
d'être avec merci de nous avoir invité
extrêmement courageux de votre part et
et Moix je vous appelle comme ça parce
que c'est la BRI qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez Eric Naulleau vous vous êtes
d'accord avec la décision de gabyle ou
pas je suis 100% d'accord pour une
raison très simple c'est que la France
c'est une République laïque c'est
première article de la Constitution et
une République laïque ça veut dire deux
choses ça veut dire le droit de croire
ou ne pas croire et c'est la neutralité
de l'État et tout ce qui est attaché à
l'état c'est pour ça que le titre est
faux c'est pas interdiction de la
bailler à l'école c'est interdiction de
la Baya à l'école publique ça c'est la
laïcité à la française on peut porter la
Baya dans des écoles confessionnelles
pas seulement musulmanes il y a des
écoles catholiques qui acceptent là-bas
il y a mais dans la tradition française
dans la loi française de la laïcité la
Baya qui est un vêtement religieux et
donc prohibé c'est pas moi qui le dit
que c'est un vêtement religieux c'est
l'imam chalumi donc c'est pas voilà un
musulman il y a la oui mais enfin il est
humain
je finis juste il y a la première imam
de France qui a même dit que ce vêtement
était un vêtement d'endoctrinement
religieux donc c'est pas seulement les
vilains fascistes d'extrême droite qui
sont là au sein de la communauté
musulmane beaucoup de gens savent très
bien que ce vêtement qui a été imposé
par un certain Islam rigoliste par les
Frères musulmans pour les nommer est un
vêtement religieux donc il n'a pas sa
place à l'école publique mais il a sa
place dans la rue chez vous où vous
voulez mais pas à l'école publique la
situation est extrêmement simple en fait
elle va vous répondre dans un instant et
là je voudrais avoir la vie de Yann Moix
je suis à titre personne indigné mon
cher Cyril par cette décision et pour
une raison très claire il me semblait
mais peut-être que je suis naïf que la
mission de l'école c'était de faire la
chasse aux fautes d'orthographe aux
élèves mauvais en calcul je ne savais
pas que l'école avait comme mission de
faire la chasse aux musulmans je ne
savais pas que la Bayette est un signe
religieux étant donné que gold che
guebwana etc les plus grandes marques
peuvent vous vendre des abayas
Pinko bingo et d'autres marques je ne
savais pas non plus si vous voulez que
le jour de la rentrée scolaire la
République française avait vocation elle
est stigmatiser des gens face caméra
alors que la rentrée déjà quelque chose
de stressant mon cher Cyril en soi pour
demander pourquoi tu t'habilles comme ça
petite et ce qui me désoblige encore
plus c'est l'effet zoo si vous voulez la
République qui toujours pose des
difficultés au journaliste lorsqu'ils
veulent aller faire des reportages dans
les écoles là pour une fois ces journées
portes ouvertes venez-vous de quel bois
on chauffe venez voir un peu que de à
quel point nous sommes des durs à cuire
voyez à quel point la laïcité est
quelque chose d'important pour nous
Cyril la laïcité à coup de trick je ne
comprends pas la République à coup de
fouet je ne la comprends pas pour moi ce
qui est important c'est que la laïcité
s'imprègne par capillarité par
intelligence dans des conversations mais
certainement pas de manière punitive la
laïcité punitive est contre-productive
et je crois que il y a quelque chose
qu'il faudrait comprendre dans ce pays à
force de créer des polémiques
incessantes parce que là il y a des
éditoriaux et des une à l'infini est-ce
qu'on pourrait 5 minutes laisser les
musulmans en paix alors on a eu la ligne
max et Derrick novo j'aimerais faire un
petit tour de table avant d'avoir des
live et son papa ni là forcément qui est
qui est en colère à la suite de sa
décision Moundir je t'ai vu hocher la
tête qu'on t'a entendu Eric alors ce que
je vais dire là je n'ai pas fait en 20
ans Cyril
s'il y a des choses qui vont vous gêner
à toi ou à la production ou à la chaîne
vous pouvez me virer d'accord je suis
extrêmement fier d'être français bien
évidemment je suis d'autant plus fier
d'être musulman et j'essaie d'être un
bon pratiquement
eric est en train de justement parler de
laïcité mais quand on prend des
historiens et spécialistes de la St
comme
ce sont des gens s'ils étaient là tu
prendrais une fessée culturelle pourquoi
je dis ça je dis ça parce que
si ces filles ou ma sœur qui est en face
de moi si c'était un vêtement islamique
qui irait dans des écoles islamiques
visiblement apporte une perte de baskets
une paire de stasmi je pense pas que la
paire de sasmine soit islamique non plus
je pense qu'au bout d'un moment il va
falloir que la France mon pays ne se
trompe pas dans son histoire et dans ses
valeurs voilà tout simplement moi ces
choses qui me touchaient énormément nos
parents nous disaient à l'époque quand
ils ont émigré justement d'Algérie parce
que ils ont voulu pour nous qu'on est
une meilleure vie pour pas qu'on a subir
ce que eux ont subi et que on a toujours
été respectueux et aujourd'hui alors que
l'école va extrêmement mal les
professeurs se font tabasser se font
poignarder il y a pas de porte il y a
plus de sport et la seule chose qu'on
trouve à mettre plutôt que donner de
l'espoir mais plutôt du désespoir et
aussi je pense aussi aux parents à leurs
enfants
on leur dit exactement bah toi tu vas
pas rentrer toi tu vas rentrer donc en
fait
pour globaliser tout ça Siri c'est que
les écoles vont devenir des boîtes de
nuit un peu comme l'ambiance qui a eu
tout à l'heure et que les chefs
d'orientation vont être des videurs toi
tu rentres toi tu rentres pas
toi je sais pas ils vont employer
cristina Cordula exactement à chaque
fois
moi j'ai entendu tout à l'heure il y a
de moi que je vous adore mais alors
quand vous dites que c'est une chasse
aux musulmans enfin non quoi c'est pas
du tout une chasse aux musulmans déjà
l'argumentation c'est à dire que c'est
pas vêtement religieux si c'est pas un
vêtement religieux quand on demande dans
l'enlever ça n'est pas des
systèmesophobie par définition je
voudrais juste vous poser une question
est-ce que vous savez que trois quarts
des élèves handicapés en France ne
peuvent pas aller avoir une scolarité
normale vous croyez pas que l'école
avait priorité plus intelligente ça
c'est un autre débat mais là pour le
moment on est sur la Baya très étrange
bah en tous les cas la laïcité qui pour
une fois alors on sort d'une période
avec Monsieur Ndiaye qui a dit au
recteur au prof m'a débrouillez-vous ce
qui est quand même dingue enfin je veux
dire il y a eu
intelligence des directeurs d'école mais
c'est pas eux de faire ça ils ont
suffisamment de poids sur les épaules
c'est à l'état de définir et de dire de
nous dire ce qu'est la laïcité il
considère que la Baya relève de la loi
de 2004 à partir de ce moment-là les
choses sont en effet sur une dernière
il faut répéter que la laïcité c'est une
c'est pas du tout une attaque contre les
musulmans ni contre aucune religion
c'est la possibilité de de de suivre sa
foi et d'exercer sa foi dans son
intimité que ce soit dans un lieu de
culte que ce soit chez soi et de ne pas
la manifester et dans la rue et dans la
rue absolument et ce n'est de ne pas la
manifester dans ce qu'est l'école de la
République et moi il y a quelque chose
auquel je suis très attaché c'est
l'égalité entre tout le monde l'école de
la République c'est qu'il n'y ait pas de
différence et qu'il n'y ait pas de
différence non plus ça passe aussi par
les vêtements on pourrait parler de la
pauvreté et des riches par les vêtements
c'est pour ça moi que je personnellement
pour le port d'un uniforme ou d'un
uniforme on va dire assez moderne et je
pense que ça crée aucune différence
c'est important que dans l'école de la
République il n'y ait pas de différence
entre les musulmans et n'importe comment
expliquer que les islamistes postes à
qui mieux mieux sur les réseaux sociaux
des tutos de démonstration en expliquant
à des jeunes filles aussi jeunes à la
vie de son papa et vous alors je vais
vous faire que réagir et vous il faut
mettre la Baya comme signe
d'appartenance religieux et que c'est
une bonne manière de faire progresser
l'islamisme les islamistes vous explique
la vérité après vous pouvez m'expliquer
vous pouvez faire oui oui au pays de la
Baya mais ça marche pas oui oui au pays
de la Baya c'est pas la France la France
c'est un pays laïque il y a des règles
c'est une arnaque de faire croire que
c'est dirigé contre les musulmans car
les signes distinctifs des juifs ou des
chrétiens sont également prohibés par
l'école de la République la République
et laïque l'école de la République est
la une république une démocratie qui
utilise l'interdiction pour asseoir ses
valeurs est une république une une
démocratie qui est faible la force
autoriser la force ça n'a jamais été
d'interdire première chose et la
deuxième c'est que je peux très bien
vous rejoindre juste pour le débat mais
c'est une sorte de tonneau des Danaïde
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait si vous
interdisez c'est-à-dire qu'en fait c'est
un tonneau vous le remplissez et se vide
à manière volante les gens
trouveront toujours une façon
vestimentaire inédite renouvelé nouvelle
originale de faire passer en contrebande
si vous vous souhaitez un signe
religieux ils en inventeront un autre ça
sera peut-être un signe microscopique
sur l'ongle ça va peut-être une
casquette à l'envers est-ce que vous
étiez est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
le principe de la laïcité qui a été
emporté au début du siècle dernier votre
prénom Jacques en fait pour une raison
très simple c'est que vous oubliez et
après je me tais mon cher Cyril une
petite dimension très importante dans la
liste et laïcité c'est considérer que
l'État ne peut pas voir un signe
religieux c'est à dire que vous mettiez
une croix ou une casquette un jean ou
une habaya en fait pour l'État ça
revient au même c'est ça la laïc Alex
mais l'école parle de la religion
il y a des cours d'histoire où il parle
de la religion à l'école le problème
n'est pas là le problème c'est que moi
j'ai la chance depuis que j'ai fait
l'humani et pendant le confinement de
parler avec le mystère du question avec
tous les professeurs je travaille encore
avec des professeurs Julie avec la
Mission laïque française la réalité
c'est que les profs étaient à bout oui
et qui avait des problèmes partout et
donc là vous avez un ministre qui est
nommé le 20 juillet qui est le 28 août
c'est une conférence avec pas que ça des
milliards des milliards beaucoup
d'annonces hyper positifs pour plein de
choses pour les professeurs pour pour
les élèves pour pour le savoir en disant
je vais pousser les bonnes heures
seulement
ça fait partie du harcèlement ça c'est
pour ça que moi aussi je suis pour
l'uniforme à l'école parce que même
quand on est habillé avec des fringues
hyper hyper riches
excuse-moi
tu peux pas dire que d'abord le Centre
islamique de Paris a bien dit que ce
n'était pas les images tu ne peux pas
dire que ça
que cette robe là longue peu importe une
fille peut s'appeler Marie est porter ça
elle va être jugé comment une fille qui
a un problème avec son corps qui est
corporel et qui veut s'habiller large la
tête non mais attends s'il te plaît on
est des copains en plus donc pour le
coup pour le coup je suis en train de te
dire que ça ce n'est pas du harcèlement
ceux qui font du harcèlement c'est ceux
qui veulent taper sur des filles entre
14 15 et 16 ans et qui veulent pas les
laisser libre alors on va on va revenir
là-dessus dans un instant noir la vie
donnez-la hein qui est la principale
intéressée en plus donc elle nous dira
ce qu'elle en pense vraiment de Gilles
Verdez j'attends et puis bien sûr les
autres Géraldine Kelly Valérie Bénaïm et
Raymond